today's weekly update of on-chain
metrics for the Bitcoin Market is with
Will Clemente we have a great
conversation as he breaks down so many
of the different data points don't
forget that these are brought to you by
ftxus you can click on the link in the
description to learn more about what
they're doing let's get into this
episode with Will I hope you all enjoy
these and learn everything every
Saturday morning will what's going on
brother
yo yo how's it going man I am uh I'm
back at the parents house for two weeks
and I got a pimple so it's like it's
like old time
back at the parents house and you got a
pimple what what an opening line all
right let's Jump Right In we've got
about 20 minutes or so uh the FED they
announced they raised rates by 75 basis
points Bitcoin goes up what's your read
yeah I think you know just the general
perception from like a high level is
that you know as the FED continues to
raise rates uh and as this week we've
gotten you know a second negative GDP
print uh essentially the market is kind
of approaching this as well you're
getting to the point where the FED is
going to have to you know kind of take
their foot off the gas pedal in terms of
at least the pace and aggression of
um how they've been raising and they
said that in their meeting as well that
they're going to kind of slow the
interval between one they've been
raising uh the FED doesn't meet us again
until September so I think that kind of
sets up some out of a window just from
that perspective for a little bit of
Market rally all right now we see
bitcoin's price is reclaiming the 180
week uh kind of trend line here what is
this showing us sure yeah so like the
first two charts are just basic like
super high time frame Trend charts so
we're looking at one weekly and one
monthly the one you brought up is the
180 week ehma so this is called the
exponential whole moving average it's
just a moving average that has more
weighing to recent price action
um and so whenever it's green as you can
see the entire Charter screen that
indicates that it's in an uptrend so
this is a good kind of meme line to show
you that over the long term Bitcoin kind
of only Trends up because the moving
average only Trends up
um and also as you'll notice by looking
at the chart uh historically it's kind
of indicated kind of these macro
bottoming or accumulation areas uh and
this is something that we've talked
about for several months uh and as we
approach this we said hey this is
probably a pretty good time to start
averaging in uh and then kind of the the
sign of confirmation would be reclaiming
that line
um so for Bitcoin one thing that I've
noticed over the last two years and also
looking at you know historical data as
well
um is that kind of these failed
breakouts and breakdowns had been almost
a better signal than actual breakouts
and breakdowns
um in general so like an example would
be the double top of last year right we
kind of deviated above the previous
all-time high from May of last year in
November of last year another example
would be the summer of last year when we
deviated below 30k before initiating
kind of that second leg up uh into the
into the back half of the year so on a
similar note if we did reclaim this that
would essentially make all the price
action below that what's called a
deviation so you have kind of this
um all this activity that goes on below
that Trend once it breaks back below it
basically invalidates the breakdown
initially and so you can see the same
thing with the 200 week as well
one thing to keep in mind though and
very important to keep in mind is That
these channels haven't closed yet so
they'll close Sunday at 8 pm eastern
time you know the reason they say it's
important to close is if you look at the
weekly for example uh you had kind of
gotten this Wick above the 200 week uh
but you know we ended up closing below
it at the last second Chrysler dropped
below before the weekly closed last week
so for now it does look good but you
know just for you know kind of these
more High time frame kind of trend-based
Market participants maybe you want to
wait uh to see if that candle close on
Sunday evening to get that confirmation
that it has been reclaimed but both of
these look good so far the market cap of
usdc and usdt the stable coin dollar
base stable coins uh you've been talking
about now for a couple of weeks uh the
relationship between those and and price
what what are you seeing here as we see
this starting uh to kind of move a
little bit
yeah sure I would throw so that initial
chart and the chart below it are both
kind of in the same family I would say
the first one is a better indication the
second one's more just something to look
at Confluence so we'll focus on that
first one
um like you said this is looking at the
market capitalization of usdt which is
tether and usdc which is circle coin
um and comparing that to the aggregated
total crypto market cap and so what you
see is that you essentially have this
kind of channel in the top section of
the chart on the screen whenever you get
to the bottom end of the channel and the
reason that I have it read is because
that's historically marked one of these
topping areas and from first principles
this chart actually makes a lot of sense
so it's indicating to you that there's
been a lot of dry powder deployed in the
market relative to uh the size of
kryptos market cap so therefore there's
a lack of new marginal buyers and so
that kind of from first principles
indicates to you that they're probably
likely in an area of you know topping
out from very high time frame sense
um you know this chart is looking at
like you know multi-month kind of kind
of swing trade type of time frames and
then along the top end of the of that
kind of ascending range or ascending
Channel what you see is that whenever it
hits the top end of that range that
indicates that there's a large amount of
dry powder on the sidelines relative to
the size of the aggregated crypto market
cap and so the way I kind of think of
this is it's very like um you know like
dry Kindle and and you know when you
have a spark the more Kindle there is
that that's laid out the more likely
that you are to see that kind of fire
spread uh and so the more dry powder
that there is on the sidelines you know
as you see any type of rally that
increases the likelihood that just from
a psychological standpoint you're going
to see a higher likelihood of Mark
participants wanting to chase uh and so
you are starting to see you know I
posted this about a month ago when it
initially whipped up to the top of that
range but now since then over the last
you know couple weeks what you've
started to see is that started to kind
of roll over off the top of that that
trend line uh and so to me what that's
indicated dating is you are starting to
see some of that on a relative basis dry
powder being deployed into the market
when we look at mvrvz score this is one
that I think you and I started talking
about I don't know year year and a half
ago
or so what uh what is this showing us
now it's down in the green zone my
friend
for sure yeah um you know we talked
about this as you said for a long time
what we always said was oh if this ever
got back into the screen range it would
be a tremendous time to average in
um and you know we got back into that
green zone over the last month or two
and at that time period we came on the
show and we said hey look this is a good
time to average in uh it does appear now
that the you know indicator has
successfully you know shown another time
to average in as well you know that
doesn't mean that you know these lows
can't get retested
um but you know as we kind of head out
of this accumulation range uh it does
appear that we're kind of moving away
from that area where uh was you know an
incredible kind of you know multi-year
opportunity to buy I think there is a a
you know pretty strong likelihood that
we were to retest that
um but just to say that you know this
the uh the market has respected the
green zone again and uh if we get back
into the green zone I would definitely
be averaging in as as I have over the
last you know month or two you know
within it you got the 200-day trend here
uh as Bitcoin continues we got another
green signal what's this showing
yeah we love we love the the green stuff
Green's a cool color
um yeah so like a month ago I had posted
this uh this tweet below and says you
know Bitcoin has only ever been this far
below it's 200-day moving average a
handful of times less than two percent
of its existence Each of which looked
terrifying to buy at the moment but
terrifyingly obvious in hindsight uh and
so now when we kind of fast forward a
month from there as you can see we've
now exited that green range and we're no
longer that far below uh this deviation
from the trend that historically has
marked bottoms uh and so again not to
say that it's impossible for that to be
retested I think there's you know a
stronger than 50 likelihood that that
that probably is retested by the end of
the year
um but you know that's not to say again
that I think this uh you know this is
served well again and we used it in real
time to indicate a good time to average
in and if we were to head back down
below this you know to this low of a
deviation uh to this far of a deviation
from that 200-day Trend I'm looking to
be getting some more spot Buys in as
well when we go and we look at the
derivatives a three-month basis has
recovered slightly uh and there's even
this backwardation explain this
yeah so um when we we've been talking
about derivatives you know we kind of
made this like mental checklist for
things that we want to see uh one of
which has been seeing uh the three-month
features basis go into backwardation
um and so this has been something that's
fueled bull market so if we look at you
know like 2020 to 2021 we saw this rip
up to like 45 what this meant is that
you could long spot short Futures and
then capture the difference uh and so
that you know this really rips high in
times of like high speculation everyone
wants to get long BTC and it creates an
ARB opportunity uh for Market
participants that are like delta neutral
meaning like they're you know they have
no directional bias essentially uh like
that and arbitraging funding are like
the two main ones that took place oh and
also obviously the grayscale one uh but
that was more towards the the back half
of 2020
um but yeah like those those two or
three were kind of the main drivers I
would say of that kind of fueled the
bull market
um and as we can see right now we're you
know back from we reached as low as like
0.27 and even backwardation towards the
bottom on on a couple venues but now
we're back up to about 2.57 so right now
you can long spot short Futures and
capture the difference uh another thing
I wanted to kind of highlight is that
you're seeing kind of this lack of like
uh extreme speculation in the market on
this rally uh because this has remained
relatively muted as you can see you know
whenever we reach a period of high
speculation like early 2021 uh you know
we can reach those High you know states
of 40 45 and you see the same thing in
in funding same kind of General premise
as well yeah we've got the short-term
holder cost basis here uh we're
underneath it what is this telling us
right so short-term holder cost basis uh
explained it I feel like several times
on the show but just from a high level
uh it's the aggregated cost basis of
Market participants that have been in
the Bitcoin market for less than 155
days so we look at the market
capitalization based off when those
coins were last moved
um for that cohort of Market
participants and currently that's down
to uh 28 000
um from like 53 000 at the peak in in
December of last year this is something
that we used when we broke below to say
Hey look it's time to be cautious right
because we kind of lost what has been
historically a kind of momentum or
um trend-based kind of indicator and so
what I'm looking at here is from like a
super kind of macro perspective
this is a good indication of bearable
Trends and so if we were to reclaim this
reclaim this I think that's kind of
confirmation of you know a trend change
so look I think in this market we have
value-based Market participants and
momentum-based Market participants you
know a lot of the indicators that we've
talked about have been kind of deep
value indicators and so those you know
those are for those value-based Market
participants like myself like yourself
pump uh who have kind of this long-term
you know time Horizon and and they're
able to hold their buys for several
years uh there are also Market
participants uh that just look to follow
bitcoin's uh you know extreme in in many
cases uh Trends and so this is a good
kind of proxy for that and as you can
see in the beginning of 2019 kind of
spring of 2019 once that was reclaimed
that kind of was a good signal for uh
riding the the rest of that move up to
about 14k throughout the middle of 2019
um and you know you you didn't really
miss the Pico bottom you missed it maybe
by 500 or a thousand dollars uh but you
basically are paying the price for
getting that confirmation of the trend
so I would say for those momentum based
Market participants this is something to
keep in mind it currently sits again at
28 000 uh which is also when we look at
the chart below uh some Confluence some
nice Confluence uh with kind of daily uh
you know price structure there's pretty
much you know I want to use this this
you know kind of meme word of price or
you know price gap or error between but
you know we really had a lot of
inefficient selling between like 28 down
to 18K a lot of that in my opinion was
for selling uh why that was probably
three AC
um you know other participants that were
kind of related to a lot of the
contagion that took place
so you saw a lot of what what's called
uninformed flow so basically people that
have to sell they're not necessary you
know that could be liquidations or
people that are you know selling because
uh they have to post collateral for
um you know whether they're you know
borrowing from any of these like
centralized lenders and they work you
know all these centralized lenders are
checking all these Market participants
after three AC to see if they actually
have the collateral they do because
there's a lot of Hysteria around who
solve it a lot of that stuff took place
so you had a lot of kind of inefficient
selling down uh and so due to that price
structure really doesn't have any real
resistance up until about that 28k level
uh which is Confluence with with on
chain as well so you know whenever you
see Confluence between on-chain and
technicals that kind of strengthens
um the importance of that level in my
mind so you know I'd be looking for I
kind of you know I think kind of the
base case would be this would be a dead
cat balance to kind of that area unless
it were flipped and then you could say
Okay perhaps this is actually a you know
High time frame uh you know Trend change
so you know those are two important
levels that you know I think are are
important to to keep in mind from a kind
of trend perspective
talk to us about funding rate I know
that you've said that you want to see
more of a negative funding uh kind of
rate regime what's going on here
right so funding is based on the Delta
between uh the Perpetual Futures and uh
the kind of weighted average
um spot price across the different spot
venues and something called The Spot
index price and so what we want to see
ideally is a a regime of negative
funding and then B price grinding up on
a regime of of increasingly negative
funding so if we look at you know after
March of 2020 it was an extreme example
where you basically had a disbelief
rally off of those lows another good
example is September of 2020 and another
real good briefing example uh was uh
July of 2021 and pomp I remember when we
came on and we said you know the day
before that big short squeeze we said
hey look I think you know we said
there's there's a high likelihood of a
short squeeze the reason we said that
was because funding was increasingly
negative as price was grinding up so you
know that in an ideal world is something
that you'd say hey look this this is
going to give me high conviction that
we're going to see a continued reversal
um you know right now obviously we have
seen some some you know pockets of
negative funding over the last month or
so but at the moment we're seeing
slightly muted positive funding uh again
it's nothing of
um major concern but I'm just bringing
this up as a point to say if it were to
go you know increasingly negative as we
grind it up that would be an indication
to say okay I can have stronger
conviction uh in this kind of being
somewhat of a disbelief for Ali so more
of just put that in in this something to
look out for than necessarily something
that's like giving a particular signal
at the moment and the last thing is the
leverage ratio I know that you've been
putting these out on Twitter but explain
these
sure yeah I just kind of threw this in
here
um just because I've seen this chart
kind of circulating on Twitter as
something that people are are using
um you know similar to open interest
like the idea is similar you know gives
you an idea of the amount of like uh
pressure or contracts that are that are
built up and on top of that this will
tell you how you know how much Leverage
is
um being taken on on those contracts the
kind of calculation for this is you're
looking at the aggregated amount of uh
Futures open interest and then you're
comparing that to the amount of coins
that are on centralized exchanges and
you know from first principles that kind
of makes sense right because you're
getting a proxy for how much collateral
is essentially on these exchanges
relative to how many contracts are open
uh so that should be a good kind of
proxy for the amount of Leverage that
people are using uh I the problem that I
personally have with this metric is when
we go to the next chart what what's
happened over the last year or so year
and a half I would say is you've kind of
got this regime change in the Futures
Market where you've gone from 70 percent
of all the Futures contracts being
collateralized with Bitcoin and other
crypto assets mostly Bitcoin uh and
that's come all the way down to about 40
of the aggregated Futures open Interest
being collateralized with crypto again
mostly Bitcoin
um so you know I would say that kind of
macro kind of regime change of of kind
of the the Futures uh Market structure
that's changed in my opinion the
usefulness uh of this metric so I kind
of just threw it in there just to say
this is something that I've seen people
talking about on Twitter but it's
something that I don't find particularly
useful anymore because of kind of that
under you know that underlying like
fundamental change in the in the Futures
uh structure
how do you feel right now in terms of
sentiment wise like if you just kind of
zoom out from all the charts everything
you see Twitter you see uh kind of the
the Legacy financial institutions you
see the Federal Reserve and kind of all
the macro stuff like what's your general
sense as to where we are at the moment
you know I think um you know I spend
most of my time on like crypto Twitter
right and with all these like Anonymous
like you know random animal characters
as their profile pictures that are
Traders and stuff and I would say like
across all these people
um you know the kind of consensus is
that it seems like someone of disbelief
I would say uh and you can see that as
well in like engagement from different
uh you know Twitter accounts some that
have you know leaned majority bearish
rightfully so perhaps over the last like
month or two
um and not necessarily saying anything
against their views because again the
you know those that have been you know
airing on the side of caution over the
last like month or two or three you know
they've they've you know been prudent
and likely done well
um but I would just say like looking at
some of those you know those accounts
and their engagement seeing you know
some of these posts get you know five to
ten thousand likes for just saying
something like hey I'm not buying into
this rally
um that to me is a bit of an indication
just from like a pure sentiment
perspective that perhaps we're getting a
bit of disbelief especially when you
compared that to some accounts that in
the moment are leaning bullish so I
would say that that has been one thing
that I've noticed just like being on
Twitter all day
um but you know that that doesn't mean
too much because that's I guess just the
the crypto-centric crowd and you know
the people that are really allocating
Capital maybe aren't on Twitter but
that's just something that I've noticed
from like uh you know kind of retail
trading on on uh Twitter perspective is
that it seems like the engagement is
definitely on the side of those who are
kind of leading cautious so
I love it what um where can we send
people to uh to follow you on Twitter
sure yeah my uh Twitter accounts W
Clementi
W Clemente III how many followers you
got now you're over seven hundred
thousand
uh I don't know about that man it's it's
definitely slowed down that's another
thing I'll say is that um you know I'm
sure you've noticed this as well is that
engagement I would say is kind of like
dropped off a cliff just in general from
like follower account all that stuff but
like the rate of change over the last
like few months you know I'll check it
like once a month or so and just kind of
use it more of like not just to say like
in like a narcissistic way of like how
many you know how many followers did I
get this month but like more so I think
it is somewhat of a good data point to
say okay hey look you know in you know
uh September or November of 2021 you
know I added like whatever 100 000
followers or something and you know this
last month I added like you know nine or
ten thousand so it's showing you you
know there's definitely a decrease in
the rate of change of New Market
participants coming into the crypto
space
I think that that's actually a a very
fair uh analysis like like it's a great
data point that shows just how much
interest is there from outside of the
community right the following is uh is
who's already in the community and then
how many people are coming from outside
makes uh makes a lot of sense
um all right my friend we will we will
continue to do these I appreciate you uh
you jumping on and uh we'll uh we'll
speak soon all right thanks a lot Bob
all right later buddy I hope that you
all enjoy these conversations with will
I learned a ton and they're very
entertaining and informative don't
forget that these episodes are brought
to you by FTX you can click on the link
in the description to learn more FTX not
only has incredibly cheap fees sometimes
as much as 85 cheaper than their
competitors they also have digital stock
trading where you can trade stocks and
crypto in the same location that digital
stock trading comes with no transaction
fees and no payment for order flow so
you get best pricing FTX continues to be
one of the most Innovative companies in
finance and in the Bitcoin and crypto
industry go check them out today by
clicking on the link in the description
and let me know what you think in the
comments